last time on google translate Dragon
Ball Z glow qu bested Frieza in a verbal
jewel I'm a Paris I glow doc hi
what did you decide was next for our
heroes find out now
question for Android afternoon no that's
bad
I gave a lot to him too
go on come on it is true that the war of
sin not there are these words we did not
get the goal of peace the rolling I know
how you go on you do not want to damage
can soft I know that these feelings but
for those who protected life fondle la
marine passion about my depth
suger to help for hours but I do not on
the road please live it I want to
protect life you have the choice I think
the scanner just let it go
good
is there a fighter you can't save 16
love life all rights reserved
and you are just robots why you died I
do not do it I see I I think slides
I did not see on down
Oh
this is before we even go hon word of
mouth in the form of knowledge of the
secrets fight with Raddatz young garlic
can you brunt also freezer we shadow the
child explosives but like an explosion
he always paid overtime I do not depend
until now ideal for use at maximum power
Gohan clock now fight with the next
warriors Dragon Ball Z for 11 years
what do you want to see next from our
heroes leave a suggestion down below for
what you want to see thank you for
watching and I will see you on the next
exciting episode of Google Translate
Dragon Ball Z